what would you want to do for free if
you didn't have to think about bills and
all this other stuff what would you
happily dedicate your time to
for free and that thing
that thing is embedded in your purpose
that's a good starting point hey friends
how's it going welcome back to deep dive
in this episode i have the immense
privilege to speak to v kativoo who has
written this book empowered and v is
like me an educational youtuber but
unlike me she is like a published author
now having actually written publisher
book she's like mates with michelle
obama she's an activist she does a load
of stuff around helping improve access
to education for people all around the
world and genuinely there were some
moments in this conversation that really
i
brought tears to my eyes just hearing
the
the authentic and honest and
really inspiring way that v naturally
speaks about her upbringing and her mum
and the stuff that she's doing and i'm
not really one to feel emotional about
stuff but like there was something about
chatting to v for the first time that
really really got me so yeah it was it
was really good and i hope you guys
enjoyed the episode as much as i did so
yeah overall in the episode we discuss
v's journey to education and doing this
empowerment thing that she's into and we
talk about her mission and purpose that
really genuinely does seem to be to do
good in the world and i'm you know
you'll see in the episode i get a bit
flabbergasted as how as to how
altruistic her motives like genuinely
are whereas mine often tend to be far
more on the selfish side of things for
like fame and power and money and all
that all that kind of stuff anyway i
hope you enjoy the episode book is
really good you should check it out it's
actually sick and it's genuinely like a
really a really pretty like work of art
as well you'll see if you're watching
this on on the youtube channel but yeah
i hope you enjoyed this conversation
between me and v let's go for it v
welcome welcome to the show how are you
doing i'm good thank you ali how are you
i'm great i've been following your your
journey on the internet for such a long
time this is the first time actually
we're meeting in real life i know it's
it's quite exciting and it's quite weird
on the internet because you've seen
someone every day you watch their story
i know you were just in pakistan like i
know so much but now i'm like oh hi
but i already know so much and it's
quite a weird and backwards way of doing
it but
it's it's it's nice to meet you in the
flesh um so you've got this book oh
which is
it's coming up very very shortly i mean
it will it will be out by the time
people see this yes this is very cool
it's like
it's like a work of art almost i feel
like a proud mother that's so pretty
honestly i feel like this is my baby and
the insides the colors it's me it's
yellow bright it's energy it's sun it's
ah yeah what was the story of getting up
getting the book deal oh my gosh people
ask me this all the time and i don't
know if this is a regular story or this
is not a regular story but i just got an
email i got an email from my editor
mirai who is incredible and she was
having a bad day she was having a really
bad day or something like that and she
went on the internet and she stumbled
across my videos and she went into like
a six-hour video watching non-stop and
she just got to know me in that time and
she was like the moment she was done she
had to email and say
your your life and your story and your
advice it needs to be a book and she
emailed that day i think and then i
replied the next day and this journey
began and well wow when so when when was
that and how was that journey from from
email to now when the book is in your
hand so
quite ironic i don't know if it's ironic
but um i started writing the book the
same day i began my degree at harvard so
they happen at the same time so i guess
the email came
two weeks before three weeks before so
you got into negotiations the back and
forth all that stuff and then you begin
so yeah and what's that what's that
process been like for you
writing the book while doing uh doing a
degree from harvard like that's a pretty
big deal i've done some crazy stuff in
my time but that was the craziest
because
it's just two big commitments two things
that you should be giving a hundred
percent of your entire time to and i'm
doing them simultaneously so that was
quite
odd but also exciting because i think i
work best when there's lots going on
rather than one thing and i've never
just done my degrees i've never just
done one thing it's always juggling and
i like that so the process was good um i
had to take time off youtube at some
point for like two months because it got
quite a lot but um
we're here now and i have a degree and a
book now so
pretty happy yeah congratulations thank
you i saw lots of very cute photos from
your graduation yes your kind of at-home
graduation party that your family
through for you and like your friends
and balloons ah listen let me tell you
something when it comes to celebrating
and celebrating life my family don't
play games they are unapologetic about
the fact that
you've gotten this far as in anyone it
could be me could be anybody you've
gotten this far through your hard work
and life is not easy the world puts a
lot on you especially as a young woman
who's a black young woman right the
world puts a lot on you as it is so
anytime you get a win they're like we
will celebrate this till kingdom come so
when the pandemic was happening
the schools were not giving us
graduations my family said okay that's
fine good for them but we're gonna carry
on so the balloons came out we ordered
the gowns and the whole the whole nine
yards and i was really happy fantastic
um so i want to go into a lot of the
stuff you talk in the book because
really like the whole thing live your
life with passion and purpose
um and
you've got some interesting thoughts
around how to find your purpose and goal
setting and all that kind of stuff
before we get into that i wonder if we
can talk a little bit about
your your background kind of your
childhood all that kind of stuff because
it's it's quite inspiring story so for
people who maybe aren't familiar with
your story i wonder if you can give us
like an overview of kind of where have
you come from and how did we get how did
we get here
so i was born and raised in zimbabwe a
beautiful beautiful beautiful country on
the southern tip of the african
continent and i was raised there up
until the age of about seven and in that
time frame my father passed away when i
was about two my mom moved to england
when i was two and then my sister
instantly got separated from me because
obviously you're gonna stay with family
members while your mom's away and they
can't afford to have both of you so we
were split up so i think being born and
then straight away your family is gone
that was really really hard and i was
raised as an orphan i had orphan status
in zimbabwe and that was really
difficult because people treat you
different like you feel the constant
sympathy and all that kind of stuff and
then we got reunited when i was about
seven or eight and then i moved to
england to be with my mom and that story
of getting to the airport is always a
funny but sad one for me because we
literally got to the airport my sister
and i after being reunited and
we saw two women my mom and her best
friend and i was like
i literally don't know which one she is
that is how much i just didn't know her
and my sister ran to one person i ran to
the other and of course i got the wrong
one and um yeah but since that day my
mom and i have been like best friends to
make up for lost time i think we bonded
so quickly and now we're inseparable you
know
and then yeah i got to the uk
went to school and wanted to go to
oxford that was a big deal for me
because i thought life it's for the
living and i want nothing but the best
that it has to offer so i went to oxford
well when i wanted to go to oxford my
teacher said no
she was like no it's not for people like
us and that was not gonna work with me
because my mom
since since we've been reunited she just
she just wanted me to have everything
like she wanted me to go after life
because it'd been so hard to begin so
when i said i want to go to uni her
instinct was well we're gonna we're
gonna choose whichever one the best one
which one's the best one google it
came up that was literally how we chose
i typed in google what's the best where
is the best place to study history
oxford came up i said that's where we're
going so when she said no it didn't make
sense to me i said but why you know and
then i didn't end up going sadly because
i just didn't have my school support and
then the next year the foundation year
came around i applied for the foundation
year got into oxford started youtube and
then the rest is history what is the
foundation year ah the foundation year
so it was this pilot scheme and course
at lady margaret hall oxford which was
like a bridging course to kind of help
students from backgrounds like mine who
would have wanted to go to a place like
oxford but because of circumstances out
of their control they just couldn't or
they maybe didn't meet the grades or
whatever the reason could be this is
like a foundation year like um
a bridging course or a fast track to get
you up to speed with what you might have
missed out on in that year before you do
your undergraduate so
you get onto the foundation year you get
to oxford you're there but you're not
yet there
so i had to like wake up from my room
at oxford to go downstairs to interview
for oxford by my professors who've been
teaching me for the past few months and
they're like hi
how are you i'm like we we we've done
this before like come on and then you
find out when whether you've gotten in
or not by going downstairs again to open
your letter in the principal's office
instead of it being sent home
so that is like such an odd way but
yeah which is a course that they took on
10 students from the uk
and i was one of them luckily i was
really happy about that but only seven
of us got to continue so it wasn't
guaranteed that you would go on to do
the degree at oxford so yeah that was
really hard yeah really hard and and why
did you go for history
that's a good question i just i love
understanding the world and my place in
it and for me to do that i have to go
back in time to understand how things
work i can't just take things to face
value like i need to know but why like
where did this begin you can't tell me
this is like the philosophy of education
i need to know what is philosophy where
does it begin like who are the first
philosophers or help me understand just
the core of something in the start of it
things like anything like racism
politics whatever like we didn't just
end up here something started or
something happened first and i love
investigating so
that's why history for me okay
so that's interesting so like a lot of
people i know included like well me and
all of the people i know from immigrant
immigrant backgrounds yeah would not
study something like history because the
mindset would be what the hell are you
gonna do with a history degree become a
history teacher yeah and and so for a
lot of people that i know it's like
medicine engineering law are like the
only professions yeah and therefore are
the only things that you can possibly do
at uni otherwise you're going to end up
i don't know
unemployed or whatever like was that
something that went through your mind at
all or no no my mom i honestly i think
the world needs to have my mom have her
own show have her own book like she is a
character within herself but when she
was raising my sister and i she never
had
any expectations on us so i never got
that aspect of oh my god you must become
a doctor or a pilot or she was just like
you must become a v that was her thing
and whatever it is i wanted to do she
would then follow suit so she'd just
wait for me to tell her this is
direction and then she would figure out
a way of supporting that or
just listening or whatever she could do
so she's got this let them fly mentality
so i never i never had that pressure i
mean there was a time she mentioned the
word doctor but like she said any kind
of doctor she never specified so if i do
a phd then technically she gets her
dream right but um yeah she supported
the history dream at some point it was
music at some point it was spanish like
i never went down the lawyer the
traditional route never was in me okay
so then you started at oxford um what
was that experience like for you broadly
yeah
gosh well i mean the first thing is
obviously the lack of diversity is is a
big big thing that plays a big role in
your experience if you're not a student
who's from that background right so as a
young black woman stepping in and only
seeing like that my year i think had 32
black students out of like 3 000
undergraduates or something like that
and that is a big big big difference
right and there are what 30 colleges or
32 in oxford so all of us are split
amongst those colleges so you might be
two or three maximum of you in your
college and that was so different to
what i'd known before so that was a
little bit hard but it was fine because
i made friends and my college was really
nice but also been on the foundation
year
made it like an extra layer because
people were
asking all the time like what is that
like what do you mean your foundation
your student what does that even mean
and how come you're saying you're not
sure if you'll be here next year like
we're all freshers and i just had to
keep on explaining i mean actually year
zero not year one so next year is my
first year but this is my year zero
they're like why didn't it be a zero so
i think that made the experience a
little bit more difficult and because i
can compare from my actual first year to
my zero first year i can see the
difference like that yeah i was tense
and i was constantly like feeling like i
need to explain
my place all the time and justify it and
because it was so new this course we
literally had people from tv shows
wanting to do documentaries on us right
they were emailing all the time we had
newspaper people we had politicians come
and visit us we had all like the
attention was crazy because people were
like wow oxford doesn't do this and now
cambridge after like four years has
adopted the course onto their stuff so
it's been slow but people are finally
getting around to it and it was just
weird being the first on there yeah so
so you said that it was it was hard
being one of 30 something black students
in yeah in the year group yeah
why why was that hard uh like yeah
it was hard because
you you are constantly speaking for your
entire race right whenever something
goes on yeah it's well
what do the black students think and
it's like we were so small such a
minority group that you're always
feeling like you're representing all the
time you know when conversations of hair
come up and you change your hair again
and again no one's already told people
i'm black i changed my hair it's
protective styling today i have blonde
hair to when i have red i can have long
hair could have short hair it's just how
it works people are always asking stuff
you're cooking your food like what is
that it's just like a constant thing and
then the boys will start telling you oh
on my bucket list it's a date of black
girl and you're always seen in your race
and not just as a person so being a
small group of you it's magnified
because i don't know you and then you
start to feel paranoia about certain
things that aren't even like happening
because you're on defense you're already
like if i speak right now this is just
what v thinks and don't
put me in with everybody else because
we're not the same and they'll just like
paint you with the same brush right as
if
all black students have the exact same
experience or the same thoughts it's
like no get to know us as individuals
stop saying acs african caribbean
society just lumping us together all the
time you know so
i felt like i couldn't just be a student
i felt like there was a responsibility
that came with my place and also knowing
that you need to do access work because
you got to make sure more of you get in
so that this experience is no longer
alien or oh my god v is there and she's
black it should be v is there yay you
know and it's not necessarily because
i'm black so i knew i couldn't just be
there and party and just be like a
student i had to also do all this work
to make sure other students like me came
in so that we can
change narrative a little bit but
yeah there are many reasons why it was
hard but that's just a little bit of why
yeah like it's it's it's hard to really
imagine that like it was kind of the
same at cambridge like very few black
students in each year you'd be lucky if
in a college there was like one or two
black students um
i think when it came to asian students
there were always many more like still a
minority compared to white people but
like
a sufficient critical mass that for me i
never felt like yeah i was like one of
maybe like five or six brown kids in the
college but there were there were enough
overall that yeah i didn't feel that
kind of i was representing my race yeah
i think black people just get it worse
than asian people asian people do it's
just
we win
yeah no it was it was difficult like it
was really really hard and people always
knew you because you stick out more so
and then when things are happening your
college or university will always call
you to do the press things and they
always say come on come on like can you
speak for us and you just think no
actually because i think that as an
institution you have a lot of work to do
and before we now stand up for you you
need to stand up for us and show up for
your students and show out for them and
stop saying that you want to diversify
and then don't really do it like
stormzy offers a scholarship and you
turn it away turn it away yes and then
it went to cambridge like what do you
think like things like that
why would you say no and you can't you
can't tell us why
things like that you just get a little
bit tired and you feel like am i
fighting the world just just to exist in
this space
do you want me here you know and that's
why the channel began truthfully that is
that is why i started doing youtube
because i was like
i can't keep doing these conversations
with people that i don't think care i
might as well just go to the internet
and tell young black students you can be
here and you deserve a space here if you
want to occupy it and you don't have to
change who you are just come as you are
i've never quite been able to make the
argument for this to other people
because
when it comes to the diversity stuff i
guess some people would say well
it's not like the university is being
systematically racist and kind of
oppressing black
black people for example it's just that
black people don't get the grades
what what do you say what do you say to
that
always been like
yeah that one makes me really really
angry because i don't think that
there is a shortage of young intelligent
talented
and incredible black students in the uk
i think there's a lack of opportunity a
lack of nurturing and often a lack of
love that's what i really think and if
you're in a school like mine like i just
shared my teacher saying no does that
mean v wasn't smart enough no because at
that exact time that i went up to them
to ask about this oxford journey three
a's
top a's like you couldn't question them
and it was what the time when you could
only do your a levels like first year
then second and you get your results so
i couldn't have scored better if i
wanted to so
at that time what's the reason to say no
to a student who's passionate and has
the grades
and then what if i don't apply now you
think there's not a lot of black
students that are smart but there was
one she just didn't have the support to
get here so
where do we go with that argument really
and truly and also if you are in a
school like the school i was in where
you'll go into class and you've now
gotten that a in your first year and you
know you're on track to get your a stars
you walk into class and they're telling
you you're sitting next to someone who
got an e fair enough love it let's all
help each other i need to get my
education right now i can't babysit
someone else because they need to be
looked after by a teacher who's
who can support them they need to be in
a different class because now what are
you going to do when you have an a
student and an e student you've got to
teach at b grade
you have to teach at b grade do i have a
chance of getting that a star really so
is it a lack of smart intelligent black
students or is it a lack of funding a
lack of resources and a lack of support
in our schools that's the question i
would want to ask let's have that
conversation
with whoever's saying that yeah
we're going to take a very quick break
to introduce our sponsor brilliant
brilliant is a fantastic online platform
for learning maths science and computer
science with interactive and engaging
courses that i've been using for many
years but to be honest i wish i'd had
their lessons in maths to hand when i
was preparing for my bmat when applying
to medical school a lot of the time when
we're taught maths at school the focus
is on empty memorization of formulas
that we can apply in our exams but the
great thing about brilliant is their
courses teach you how to actually
understand concepts from a first
principles approach and develop the
intuition to solve problems also their
computer science series is absolutely
sick they've got some fantastic courses
on algorithms on learning to program
with python they've got a whole series
about cryptocurrency and understanding
exactly how things like bitcoin work
from the ground up which is genuinely
fascinating so if you want to give their
lessons and maths a try or even science
or computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up by
that link will get 20 off the annual
subscription to the website so thank you
so much brilliant for sponsoring this
episode the other question that i've
never been able to answer is
what should the university do about this
because the problems are more upstream
they're more like earlier on in life
earlier in in childhood like the school
system the education system
and then when it comes to the actions of
an individual university you start
saying well
it's not their fault that like i don't
know the
low performing schools don't like
encourage the students as much et cetera
et cetera
and then the conversation goes so far
back and so abstract that it stops
becoming about things that universities
can do and they often use that as an
excuse to not then do stuff oh no the
conversation is still very much about
what the universities can do because let
me tell you
the journey begins with yes with family
members and how many oxford students
have you had and then you get to the
school and the lack of resources but
then they get to the point where some of
those students do still make it through
that filter system so you might still
have a student like me who finds her
school gets to that place and finally
has an interview oxford wonderful
fantastic now when she gets into that
interview there are these things called
unconscious biases right we need the
universities to start training their
professors to start helping them look
out for talent that is just beyond an a
star for example because let me tell you
something that b grade that i'm talking
about where i've earned it next to an e
student and a d student and i've now had
to fight for my class and all the stuff
that b has been earned through blood
sweat tears it stands at the same
position as that a start and people find
it difficult to understand what i'm
saying when i say that contextualize it
okay if you're in a school where there
are four of you and you're learning and
your teacher knows how many times you've
blinked your report card is accurate it
is exactly about you whereas some of our
report cards are copied and pasted when
i come out with my b grade or my a grade
you better give it some respect
all right so when you have things like
that and students like that applying to
places like oxbridge these universities
need to contextualize look into how did
that person get was their heating
working
where they able to study and revise and
for them to still have the courage and
bravery to apply and make it as far as
an interview maybe in the interview
let's give them a chance you know maybe
because people connect to people that
they're similar to so when that student
walks in and says oh my god i saw you at
the races and my dad always comes to
your club and whatever instant
connection you're like ah they get it
they'll understand they'll fit in you
get in then the student comes in coming
in from hackney they didn't have the
heating on they didn't have the school
support they're nervous they can't look
in the eye
but they've still applied and they still
managed to ace that essay and whatever
whatever can we start contextualizing
that's what i've got to say
you speak pretty passionately about it i
can like i can like feel feel feel the
passion yeah yeah yeah that's why that's
why the channel began i had too much to
say that was penned up inside and it was
just frustrating because every time i'd
go home
i'd be hearing my friends like oh my god
feel like what do they eat over there is
it lobster like they're riding around in
harry potter like gowns and all this
stuff i'm like you're so smart one of
the smartest people i know but because
of a lack of confidence a lack of
support and a lack of thinking you can
fit in a place like that we've lost you
like you're you would never even
consider coming to visit me because
you're afraid of being put at a dinner
table with five forks five knives all of
this stuff when you would have actually
like we needed you you know what i mean
we needed someone like you so i get
frustrated and passionate because i i
see the students that that are missing
out or that are at the other end of it i
i see them and i'm like
man if the world had just given you a
little bit of love yeah you could have
done wonders so that's why
wow so
given that the world is the way that it
is um what can
maybe if there's a student in that
position listening or watching to this
what can they do to kind of help take
matters into their own hands while at
the same time campaigning and wishing
the world will change alongside yeah
well that that is why the book the
channel anything that i do that's public
or on the internet why i do it is for
that reason for someone who would have
been like me who needed that older big
sister because for example my mom i told
you she lets me lead and then she
follows right she would have never been
the one who would have said oxford now
follow me and i'll help you like that
would have never happened she doesn't
know anything about it doesn't
understand how the system works and
there are lots of students like that
whose parents
literally have no clue so if there's a
student like that and then she goes to
school and the teacher's like no no no
we're not interested and also i must say
before i answer your question i don't
blame the schools either because
sometimes they just don't have an
understanding of oxbridge themselves and
they find it intimidating too or it's a
little bit like extra work we do
personal statement classes for 25
students and now v wants a separate one
for oxbridge because it's different we
don't have the time or the resources so
it's easier to say no not because their
hearts are unkind but it's just what
they know maybe and whatever so want to
highlight that as well like there could
be other reasons and yeah i can i can i
can forgive that yeah um but yes those
students who are at home who are
wondering
what they can do to kind of help
themselves get on the internet watch
youtube channels like mine the resources
are free that like you don't have to pay
for this you don't have to have extra
private tuition like get on the internet
there are so many study tubers out there
so many blogs out there there are so
many helpful things and sign up for free
classes like empowered by v like i hate
to be that person but things like
empowered by v where every year we're
having these annual events that are free
having students like myself or jade or i
mean we're gonna get you on there one
day people like jack ali coming on to
explain their experience how they write
their personal statements how things
like you just can't put a price on this
stuff you know what i mean that can be
as helpful as what your counterparts i
mean i don't know because i've never
been taro or eaten but what they could
be getting there like we're trying to
bridge the gap as much as we can so use
all of these free resources around you
because they're there for a reason and
they are helpful i must say so myself
empowered by me um
just as an aside um how how do you feel
about the fact that it's called
empowered by v like yeah your name being
part of this like yeah okay so basically
that is that is a story within itself
but i was with my friends and i was like
guys this event is coming up and at the
time we were just calling it the event
the event the event the event i was like
no we need a name like this is getting
ridiculous it needs a name and they're
like what do you want to do like what is
what's going on it's like i'll empower
people and then i just call it empowered
and we're all loved empowered like yeah
that works great then i was just like it
doesn't it doesn't feel complete there's
something missing there's something
missing and then i i suggested i was
like what if we put by v but a silent by
v at the time it was silent so it was
like just so they know it's me doing it
so like empowered and underneath it's
like it's by v yeah then they're like no
uh
it needs to be empowered by v together
and once it began it was three in the
morning yeah we had rich tis tea
biscuits we had cups of teas there was
no turning back and i was like okay okay
we'll do it for now but i was like i
don't know if if it's a right thing to
have my name in there because they're
finding their empowerment for themselves
and we're just helping facilitate that
we're not empowering them they they're
just looking for it you know
it was too late by the time we had the
event the students loved it they're like
yes this is what it's all about woo
and i try to change it every year we do
a survey i'm like guys we're going to
change it to something else they're like
no then i was like fine we'll have to
call it ebv so i refer to it as ebv
because i'm like you know it feels more
comfortable but they're like now
empowered by v so it's stuck now and and
and there's so many times i wishing you
how many times this conversation happens
every year i'm like right it's getting
bigger now like we've got 15 000
students tuned in can we change it
before we get to 20th yeah
like no people like the name no one
wants to hear it and no one wants to
hear it so
yeah i i hope that doing the book and
call of the book empowered people think
i'm talking about the book yeah but now
i'm like now it's just confusing because
it's two things like empowered
overwritten by the only powered by the
event
i don't know where we go from here the
branding is not quite yeah right
but yeah yeah i remember so when i was
um when uh jade was on the podcast and
we were talking about her book it's the
only study guide you'll ever need she
mentioned about how she cringed at first
about the name it's like oh it's a bit
much
but then it kind of grows on you and you
realize that actually i i like i just
thought it was a great name and i think
empowered by v is a great name but i
guess like
as v person you feel a bit weird about
the like
yeah and i thought about it
i was like i'm sure there are people out
there who you know like i don't know
tommy hilfiger mark jacobs where at
first they thought are we gonna really
now it's just noble right and i think
for people who encounter it for the
first time or are just coming to it it's
just it's just a name but for me i'm
like
oh because i start to think about the
word the meaning and like by v and what
does that mean am i the one doing it am
i yeah but i you have to sometimes also
let things have their own life so this
is now beyond me which is crazy to say
when it's got my name but it's now
outside of me like the students have
ownership of this now and i love that
they get to shape and craft what the
things we talk about are what that
platform looks like what the instagram
does like how that platform in space
helps them they shape it so
i can't take it i can't go in there and
be like well i don't like the name so
i'm just changing it
it's too late now actually if i wanted
to three years ago was the time now
so what what is empowered by me yes i
love that question people always they're
like i don't want to ask because you're
so passionate about it and like you talk
about it for so long but can you just
tell me what it is again but um yeah
it's an academic empowerment platform so
we're just bridging the gap between
academic ability which the students
already have and self-belief which they
don't have so we're just trying to merge
the two together to be like you are that
person you better own it and start
taking up your space because the world
is it's yours for the taking and you
can't help where you were born you can't
help the situation that you're in but
you can help how you react to it and
what you do moving forward so take those
bad moments reframe them if the glass is
half full or half and look at it as half
full always never half empty because the
moment you start looking at is half
empty you're missing out opportunities
you're literally missing out what that
half glass of water could do for you
could save your life right but you're so
focused on the lack of that no and i
always tell my students as well that
even if you have walked a really
difficult journey in life that doesn't
make you less than if anything
it makes you phenomenal because if you
can end up in the same seat in the same
table as other people who've obviously
and i this is the thing people often
think that i'm really angry at people
who've had an amazing life i'm like no
that is what everyone wants to have like
i want my children to not have to suffer
like i don't think
your achievements are more we should cut
for them more because you had to
struggle like i don't want people to
struggle that is the whole point of
everything we're doing like we need
everyone to be in a place where they can
have things they like without having to
have blood sweat tears but if you have
had to have that that that shouldn't be
something you're embarrassed about like
if anything there is strength in your
story there is strength in the journey
you've walked and be proud of it because
if that's what you can do when you
didn't have a lot imagine when you have
the resources you're going to be
unstoppable like we should be afraid
right now like you are on
on your on the journey to just doing
amazing things so that is that is what
we try to do in power by v just trying
to let students know that
you are worthy of
everything you want you're worthy of
being successful you can't let your
start determine your end that is not how
it works and we're going to reframe and
so what's the other one what does that
look like in practice like how how do
you yeah empower people like this we
have workshops so many empowerment
workshops which run for like two weeks
for example and we'll take students
they'll come along ask them surveys what
are the things that you're struggling
with most and where do you think you
need help with the most they'll tell us
and it's typically it's always always
things like i don't think i deserve this
or my family comes from this background
and i'm just not sure people will look
at me in a respectful light or always
it's never to do with can you help me
with getting better grades it's never
that they know that they're smart it's
always people just don't support me or i
don't have
that
empowerment circle around me or people
who are telling me you can do it and
then we become that for them so we
figure out what they are struggling with
and then for the two weeks i just work
with it it's kind of like coaching in a
way it's like coaching and talking to
them and working through that with them
that's one element then the biggest
element is the event which is the annual
event that we do and getting all these
people who i consider experts in their
field my friends are phenomenal i think
they're doing great things and we get
them in and like okay jade you're great
at the personal statements okay eve
benny you're great at talking about
mental health and all this other stuff
so we bring them together and have this
massive conference and the students are
taking notes they're taking like
mad notes and then they always tell us
because we get feedback the feedback we
get
is crazy they'll tell us like after
three months they'll come back and be
like by the way the notes i've made from
powered by v the event i'm still
referring to now and i'm still using and
like i
am feeling it so it's just about
giving people a boost
and letting them know
you can do it because sometimes it
actually is just that someone has
literally never told you i can see you
you're worthy of this and you can do it
go
and people
it can change your mindset like for me
if that teacher told me yes
ah
that no shattered me and i didn't apply
in the end i didn't until i got that
foundation here the next year so it can
change everything for you even though
you have those a's that no or i don't
believe in you
game changer i feel like
i just lived such a privileged
upbringing
in that no one's ever really said no and
like you know things are going well you
get good grades you're like obviously
you're going to apply to oxford
cambridge obviously you're going to go
for medicine cool let's go for it like
no real adversity along the way yeah and
i guess i also don't speak to enough
people who have actually had some level
of adversity in their lives to actually
just like appreciate that that's a thing
it's it sounds like what you're saying
is that for a lot of these people they
need that
just just that boost of motivation that
actually you can just do it that is it
because imagine when you're at your
lowest like whatever that looks like for
you or whoever else when you're at your
lowest moment or you've worn an outfit
and you're doubting it you're already
like look in the mirror like i shouldn't
go out like this and the uber's outside
it's telling you come on come on let's
go and then you bump into someone on
your way out and they're like oh what
are you wearing
it's just confirmed all your fears
you're going back in that house and
you're gonna change like that oh if you
do leave you're going to be looking down
and thinking i should have never worn
this and closing your jacket and that is
the same element of like
support that people need in their
regular lives you're already thinking
man like we live above the chicken shop
right we live above the chicken shop
it's always so noisy people already look
down on me at school they laugh at me we
don't have enough money there's no gas
electricity and i'm gonna go and sit
next to people who are gonna be the
future prime ministers at oxford no way
i could never go there and then finally
get courage to like tell your teacher or
maybe i'm thinking of it and they tell
you it's not for people like us
your fears are already on the brink what
you the last thing you need
is someone to confirm them especially
when they're not true and it's just like
it's just not even true your fears
getting confirmed
the worst thing so we have to come in
and like try to undo that and some of
this stuff is years in the making this
is from high school primary school which
is always been in circles of people just
being like this is it there's nothing
more to it and like i need to come in
and be like come on
you've got this and at first they're
like oh look at this girl what's shawn
about like boost of energy like girl get
out of here and by the end of it they're
like yeah
i can't do it and then when i get the
emails being like i applied and i got in
yeah oh
just fills me with joy and it's it's
every day i get those messages every day
v by the way like i i would have never
applied he
he kind of striked me as like the
modern-day tony robbins in like a great
way
because like i think every generation
has these kind of motivational people
that
really what they do is they empower
people and kind of give them permission
to do the thing which they already have
in them anyway yeah um you know tony
robbins there's this book called um the
magic of thinking big which like had an
enormous impact on me like 10 years ago
when i first discovered this kind of
stuff
and it sounds like that's what you're
doing for kind of this this current
generation of students and it happened
by mistake yeah it happened by me it was
just anger like it came from anger of
sitting there constantly at university
in that foundation yeah and just seeing
the things i was just seeing and like
hearing or feeling and i just thought to
myself
why am i looking down on myself why am i
looking in the mirror and the imposter
syndrome was hitting me i just kept
thinking they've definitely made a
mistake they're gonna genuinely come in
here and be like
what like you're the first in your
school like your family haven't do do
they even know what oxbridge stands for
like most of them are literally like
what are you talking about oxford
cambridge together oxford oh okay like
it's that kind of conversation you're
having you're not starting with which
college you're starting with this is
what oxford is and this is why i want to
go there so i just thought what are you
doing here and after i met the people i
met and they tell me that they've had
five brothers and sisters come here and
their parents met here and like their
dad paid for that building and i'm like
the first time i saw oxford was when i
went to move in that was the first time
i stepped foot in the city little in the
university was moving in day and these
were telling me they've grown up coming
here for picnics and lunch and you feel
so out of place it is ridiculous and i
thought
nah
like
i can't believe i was gonna not come
here and oxford by the way is a
representation of whatever it is in your
life that you're thinking of it could be
your dream job could be your dream
whatever i just happen to experience
this i thought i was gonna not be here
because of a lack of
confidence and a lack of support it just
frustrated me like i was so mad i was so
mad and i started the channel
and i think one of the first videos i
ended up deleting it because it was
i was like is oxford diverse is it no
it's not but we're gonna change that and
i was just literally screaming and then
obviously the channel took shape and now
it's in a better place yeah
it's it seems like you're genuinely kind
of
mission and purpose driven thank you and
like
a really
okay
so the reason i'm i'm so surprised by
this is because like
you know there's there's a quote which
apparently is often attributed to jp
morgan which is that
um
you know someone always has two reasons
for doing something um the good reason
and the real reason
and if i think about my motivations for
starting a youtube channel yeah i i
could say that you know there's you know
i want to help people i like teaching
people study tips and the comments are
nice and all that kind of stuff yeah but
really if i dig deep i i love the
attention i love the admiration the
social status the prestige the money
associated with it that kind of stuff
um and if i have to be honest with
myself then that's probably a
significant part of why i do the youtube
thing and the internet thing on top of
like the whole yeah helping people
aspect of it um that's interesting i'm
just kind of curious like because for
you it really sounds like the helping
people is like the majority of it yes
yeah what's going on
yeah well the thing is before i began
youtube i didn't know anybody in youtube
like all my friends or people that i've
known is through doing it and like they
reach out i reach out and then now you
cross paths and then you become friends
right but i didn't know anybody and i
didn't really consume youtube i still
don't right now people always ask me
who's your favorite youtuber who do you
watch i don't really use
the app
for my own personal i just upload and i
go right so when i started it you have
to imagine like no one no one i knew was
doing it and i would i would share the
link on facebook for my friends and
family to like share to their to their
nieces and nephews whatever i was like
oh if we can get 100 people we did
something like it never
it just never crossed my mind that
youtube could be a job that blew my even
when my management approached me i said
what like i just
i don't know why i didn't know because i
guess no one talks about it on the
internet really like now it's more open
with people like you as well sharing the
stats and the figures and stuff but i
just didn't know you could actually have
a living on there and sustain yourself
so i was working in mcdonald's before i
went to uni so from mcdonald's i was not
thinking like youtube i was like we want
to get to you like a starbucks like who
knows i could level up you know that is
literally what i was thinking and so
starting it it would be so hard for my
brain to have known that yeah and i
remember literally saving every last
penny she's like we need to get
something like a camera or something
that we can use because my sister was
like oh my god like that's money you're
never gonna see again you know like it's
gonna be gone i was like
well you know if i want to make videos
what am i going to do and i no one would
have told me it was an investment
because it's going to return like i
don't even think like that so
i don't know like if i had to try and
think of what the real reason yeah
oh i was just angry yeah
that is it and i if i hadn't gone to
oxford i don't think i'd have started a
youtube channel it just came from people
kept asking me questions like what do
they eat there how do you do this
let's just send a link it's easier to
send a link it was i guess that could be
the real reason laziness i couldn't be
bothered to keep saying the same thing
over and over again let's put it on the
channel let's have everyone watching it
in their bedroom you can go back pause
rewind whatever so
i don't know
so the the success that you've had now
on on youtube one one thing that a lot
of youtubers talk about is as the
channel goes bigger
even like what what started as a um a
vehicle for
empowering people giving good
educational content that kind of stuff
now becomes like oh will this video do
well how did that video perform 10 out
of 10 oh no i feel depressed because my
video didn't perform very well oh
yeah how do you feel about the stats i
hate that feature on the thing anyway
about this one out of 10 10 out of 10.
before that i really like i just didn't
i didn't think it was necessary i don't
know who
said yeah let's give that feature a go
but please remove it wherever you are
youtube world but
once again my mom she
she is so good at keeping anybody's feet
on the ground as in she'll be like whoa
whoa whoa did you see that like over a
hundred people commented we couldn't fit
them in our back garden to give them tea
to say thank you and i'm like mom you're
so right like we actually couldn't fit
these people on our street or in our
back garden so for me to ever be
ungrateful or not ungrateful that's
wrong because it is a craft is a job and
i can see why people be bothered about
if it doesn't perform well but
for me to be
if if it's had 10 000 people watch it
that's a lot of people when artists do
sell out a show and it's ten thousand
they're like whoa
but now the internet obscures our view
and makes ten thousand seems small
and it's like
i don't know the numbers just are so big
to me they just they're so massive and
the fact that people will be watching
your story and you have like 10 replies
i'm like these are 10 human beings
who are coming into your world and then
leaving a comment or leaving a like or
watching
i can't i don't know how to explain it
my family just celebrate everything yeah
and if i was to ever go to them and say
oh my god only got 10 000 views they
would humble me so quickly like what
10 000 people
this didn't exist a few years ago and
maybe also
i need to start having that mindset of
like keeping track and tabs on the
numbers and stuff because i don't know i
don't know i don't know but as of right
now
it's like
what was the purpose of the video or the
channel
and if the purpose is to reach people
10 000 people is not about like that is
a lot of people
now if you get 100 000 or a million
that's like a bonus you know and
i don't know i wish i wish people could
like spy on my family for a week yeah
and just see us when there's no because
i think people often think oh because
the camera's on yeah that i have to say
this stuff or that i have to be like
super positive and like whoa
i wish you could see the family with no
camera
this is us 24 7. and jade i went to
visit her in berlin and she'd just been
on a bike accident and i was so sad for
her and i went to see her and my mom was
like oh she was feeling it she was like
oh my god i thought i could when it
happened i felt it i said well no you
did it you didn't feel anything stop it
but she's so like in tune with her
emotions and stuff and then when i went
to cj she was like write this in a card
for me because i couldn't see her so she
texted me and said put it in a card as
jade was reading it she was crying i was
like why are you crying like i was so
shocked because i wrote it out for her i
was like why are you crying she's like
does your mom speak like this all the
time is this just how you are like yeah
that's you got hit by a bike so she's to
tell you like get rid of the victory
slayers the people who don't want to see
you win your light shines it was full of
all this stuff and jade was like
literally sobbing and i was like oh why
she said no one says this stuff to me
and i can't believe you're raised on
this i was like this is so normal to me
that like when i read i was like that's
just her saying look at well soon right
so if you saw her family behind the
scenes it's just constant we just we
live for this yeah
so it's like kind of constantly
the like the gratitude stuff yeah
we really are and i think also it's when
you've seen
what the other side of not having it is
like right i'm very very aware that at
any moment all of this could disappear
any moment it could disappear and i
could easily there is no reason why i
could easily not be working mcdonald's
again right like yes of course now it's
a bit different maybe with the degrees
and all this stuff but a few years ago
there is
what is the real difference between my
sister and i because she's still at home
right and she's still working a regular
job and all this stuff and i just happen
to be this new world but whenever i go
home like my mom my sister my mom's
running for the bus every single day
she's she just won't she won't do her
driving lessons i don't know why but
she's still running for the bus every
single day and if i'm gonna go somewhere
with her we're getting the bus and my
sister still works a regular job and if
i say to her on my birthday or i really
want this she's like excuse me that's 50
pounds that takes me this many more
hours to get you're not having that it's
still
i could never lose sight of it because
it's it's just there it's at home and
when i call my family in zimbabwe
like
it's i don't know so 10 000 we celebrate
that it's not a low number to us
that's pretty good
i'm gonna i'm gonna clip that and like
save it on my on my computer like
whenever i see like a 10 out of 10 video
i'll be like no i need i need to
motivate call me mom call my mom that
i'm telling you this woman she's got
some classic things that she says and
growing up i would just be like oh but
mom like all my friends have barbie
dolls and they're gonna get them for
christmas and i really want one we
couldn't afford a new barbie doll no way
she'd take me to the car boot sale and
we would go through the second hand
stuff and then find a barbie doll and
i'm like but mom like it's got a scratch
and it's missing like an ear she's like
no no no no you're looking at it wrong
reframe it this barbie doll is so
special she's got a story to tell your
friends barbie doll like it's brand new
great i'm happy for them but look at
yours like can you imagine what happened
for her to lose her ear you can imagine
anything you want in your book it's got
a tea stain what was the person reading
it thinking she would make everything so
much fun and nothing was ever
be sad about this it was like no embrace
it like we found your barbie doll
special in the back of the boot at the
corner like you were meant for her you
were supposed to save her did it that
kind of stuff that was her all the time
yeah
it's so weird i'm like tearing up as
you're describing that because i'm like
i'm like feeling stuff feeling the
passion
oh stop does that look dude
yeah it's such an unusual amount of like
just positivity that you just don't
encounter in real life normally
yeah no i get this all the time yeah
even my friends that i'm friends with
now they're literally like
like i really thought it was because
you're on instagram like your story
needs to be jazzy like you wake up like
this yeah 9 a.m and you're like singing
and dancing and you're and to me it's so
normal like i don't even see as i am a
certain way i just think this is this is
it you have one life
i'm not going to waste it being sad love
it um i have so many questions about the
book um so my baby um
it's
it's really nice it's it's like it's
like very very like nice nice nicely
packaged um initially when i heard you
were you were when i heard you were
writing a book i just sort of had in my
head like uh the standard penguin
nonfiction book yes it's just so so
pretty yeah yeah yeah
i thought i i made sure like my my
editor is really incredible like i keep
saying she
she really knew me well because she'd
obviously studied my channel before she
reached out and she'd had an idea and
the fact is as well
she
messaged me what she thought she wanted
me to write and i already had a google
doc of like what i would want to write
in the future if i had a book
it matched so much
that's why i was like yes because for me
i was like you've understood me we've
never spoken before and you've actually
gotten the vision from watching random
bits of my videos and i was like yeah
we're doing this so when it came time
for the colors or the book she already
knew if it's not an explosion of yellow
bright sunshine and someone feels happy
when they see it i don't want it like
we're not doing the cool
thing or like it needs to be oh no i
want it to be exactly what's going to be
inside there yeah that's why i got
little gold little bits because when you
finish reading it i want you to just
feel like you can take over the world
um so the first chapter is about finding
your purpose yes um so
okay let's say i don't i don't really
know what and what my purpose is yeah
how do i how do i go about slash how
does a viewer listener go about
answering this question of like what the
hell is my purpose yeah that's a
question i get all of the time and i
always say
what is what is that thing that thing
that just
you can't stay away from it you keep
thinking about it and obviously this can
go wrong i do understand that like you
could be thinking some bad things and i
could be encouraging the wrong thing but
let's just begin off of the base that
it's a good thing and it's a regular
thing right what is that thing that you
can't get off your mind a debate here on
the bus and you literally strangers you
have to turn around and chime in or
anytime you have a chance to do free
things you're researching it like you
just can't stay away from it what is
that thing that thing has something in
you that is driving you like you want to
be a part of it you want to what what
would you want to do for free if you
didn't have to think about bills and all
this other stuff what would you happily
dedicate your time to
for free and that thing
that thing is embedded in your purpose
that's a good starting point so when you
figure out what that thing is and then
you follow that track for me helping
people okay you want to help people of
you what do you always do what are you
always doing oh in class you get in
trouble for teaching people you always
find yourself speaking up did it oh
maybe it's education i don't know and
then you start to like go down this
little rabbit hole until you figure out
what that specific
niche within it is and also when you're
finding your purpose it's not like you
have to make a lifelong decision like
you're married to it and that's the end
of all no you could have a purpose that
you want to pursue for the next three
years and that's that and then you're
done with it and you want to move on to
something else that's okay finding your
purpose is not
it's not final it's like what michelle
obama says you're becoming you're always
constantly becoming and things might
change who knows what v in 10 years will
be doing i hope she'll be doing this but
i might fall out of love with it or i
might feel like i've given all i can
give and there's nothing else things are
not gonna i don't know who knows but it
could change but for now figure out what
you can't stay away from what is always
on your mind what keeps you awake at
night what world problem
bothers you to the core and that is
where youtube began right i was like
man the lack of diversity is oh it's so
annoying i'm going to start a channel
so it could be oh i hate the way that i
keep seeing dogs being treated when when
they're stray dogs or when they're
abandoned oh i'm going to go to the vet
and then you're talking to the vet and
then you want a work experience then you
figure out this new thing you want to do
you just kind of like
you need to track it trace that thing
don't like ignore
the thing that's living in your heart
you know what i mean
let's say you're halfway through your
jpmorgan internship
and
the bros are like hey v how do i find my
purpose like for because like
the the way you're describing the
purpose stuff is very like mission
driven like you know what what's the
what
you want you want to solve and
to be honest if i think of most of my
friends and me as well like
we don't really have that oh my god i
just feel so passionate about like
diversity that that's going to be my
problem
and equally i can imagine a bunch of my
friends who now work at places like jp
morgan and mckinsey and stuff they're
not particularly thinking
how am i going to change the world
they're kind of thinking i want to make
a lot of money and have a good life like
well with people like that i'm pretty
sure
that when you're at jp morgan or
wherever you are i'm pretty sure when
you get home there is something that has
your interest there is something that
you try to fit in your spare hours
because you can't do it because of work
right there is a thing you've got skills
things that you're just good at whether
you love it or not you're good at it
then you have things that you really
care about or that you want to be in you
have to find a way of merging those two
worlds right you want to be able to go
to work or go to the thing that you
spend mostly time doing and love it so
if you're at jp morgan and yes you're
doing amazing you're getting all the
promotions in the world but you're still
feeling like something's missing then
that's obviously not your your purpose
your purpose is
it's the thing that you're rushing out
of work to go home to do and that could
be gaming i don't know it could be
wanting to create the most diverse game
or maybe the most interesting game that
young people can use because i don't
know or maybe you want to use a game
that people who might have disabilities
can use to do
like
you need to just find what your interest
is and then unpack it from there so even
if it is painting or maybe you love
skateboarding or whatever it may be
people had to create microsoft right we
had to get a version of microsoft and
that probably came from song and being
like i like coding or i like doing the
dirt and now microsoft went on to
help people do different things like we
use microsoft for good you know so i
think it's thinking about
what what do you like to do in your
spare time yeah in your spare time when
no one is monitoring you where you're
not being paid you're on holiday it's
christmas break okay you're at your
mom's house it's christmas break there's
a week to what you're gonna spend your
hours doing
and you might find yourself on the
trading apps or the stocks apps and you
might find actually i just like making a
lot of money that's okay too you just
got to live for you and if that thing
that you're doing is making you happy if
jpmorgan makes you happy it doesn't have
to don't have to call it your purpose
you just call it the reason i'm living i
don't know
yeah there's a um
yeah on the thing of kind of finding
your purpose there's a phrase that i
heard which is that um
you know that that that thing that you
think about in the shower is probably
the thing that you should you should
probably be doing that's what i'm
talking about and
that was that was really helpful for me
when i was trying to figure out do i
want to continue doing medicine or not
because i never think about medicine in
the shower
and i was like okay interesting and then
like at some point further down the line
uh i was i was doing a whole like deep
dive into the internet and books and
stuff to answer this question of like
how do you figure out what to do with
your life
um there was another exercise i came
across which was kind of like the sort
of uh ideal ordinary week
three years from now like fast forward
your google calendar whatever and just
block out what would you like to be
doing what is your ideal i love that and
you know what are the what are the sort
of hobbies what are the things you want
to try out what's on the bucket list and
again i kind of did this and i was like
half an hour later i was like there was
no mention of medicine anywhere on this
list ah ugh damn that's annoying
yeah cause i really i really wanted to
feel passionate about the medicine stuff
and i just realized it doesn't really
it didn't really feel like my purpose it
didn't really feel like my jam exactly
and then there was the whole like
suncoast thing around it the whole while
i've invested eight years into this
already the whole what are people gonna
say what's my mom gonna say people on
the internet gonna hate me for this
because if you suddenly leave the nhs
that's a big deal etc etc um
but it's so it's like for me i guess
it's still a work in progress but i keep
looking for other ways to kind of
because i think like as you said it's
not a permanent decision like i think a
lot of people
think of the idea of i need to find my
purpose as this is the thing i will do
for the next 80 years of my life yeah
but the way i kind of try and think of
it it's more like this is just the next
season of my life and for the next
season of my life
i like the idea of you know the thing i
think about in the shower is making
youtube videos so let's just do more of
that yeah and then maybe my plans will
change five years from now but try and
try not to think too hard about it
further down the line yeah i i love that
i really really love that you said that
about this is just the season and if
that season lasts 30 years great you had
a great season you know like it's fine
and if it happens to last a year okay
like i just quit my job i just i
literally just quit my job a week ago
and i felt great about it i thought it
was going to be one thing it turned out
to not and and i'm not going to keep
myself trapped in something because i
announced it to the internet like that
that point that is when i'll know that
something has gone wrong for me because
uh-uh that's not why we were here that's
not what this is all about and if i now
start shaping
my life based on what we'll do better
like will perform better in the views or
what people will think about it then ah
something
has gone really wrong
there's a quote that i wanted
i've been thinking about recently which
is that um
your passion is for you uh your purpose
is for others whoa discuss
your passion is for you and your purpose
is for others
i suppose i can see what they're saying
like
you could
you could have a purpose that you're
serving but you're not passionate about
it
like medicine right you could be a
really great doctor and obviously when
you are there doing your doctoring stuff
you're saving lives right and that
obviously serves all of us and the nhs
and the the uk and we appreciate it but
if you're not passionate about it then
you're not pouring into you you're now
running on empty so i think i agree with
that quote like your passion has to be
something for you so you need to love
medicine you need to have you read um
when breath is air yes like he was
living
right like even on his dying days he was
so committed to it because it was
everything for him
now imagine if if it wasn't like i don't
think that book could have read the same
right you can hear it and i think i
think your passion does need to be
something that you
love something that
it's in your core and then the purpose
follows it right because you can serve
others when you're at a hundred percent
yeah it's it's it's pretty hard like
even i guess celebrities when they've
got all of this money and they've got
all of the time and all the stuff when
they choose their causes that they're
campaigning for technically they could
put that money to good use for different
things
but they have to choose something that
they're not just the face off like you
need to be able to show up we need more
than just you putting your money in okay
it needs to be more than just a quick
instagram tag like do you really care
and i think that's that's the beauty of
being able to
define what that means because anyone
could come up to me and say
but the
the climate crisis is more important
than education right now right people
could justify any of the 17 sustainable
development goals and tell you that
actually should be this one that you're
focusing on yeah but
if if my passion is not there yes of
course i care about the climate crisis
it affects every single one of us but
it's not something that i'm gonna
invest as much as my time as i would
education and that is okay we're one
person you are not a time traveler you
can't be everywhere at once so find what
it is that for now you care about who
knows in five years i could be the
biggest climate activist in the world
who knows but for right now
you
this is what i'm doing i care about it
and i can serve people and if you can
get those two to me
magic
yeah the analogy that came to mind as
you were saying this was uh you know on
airplanes to like put your own mask on
first yeah and then before helping
someone else i feel like putting your
own mask on first is finding the thing
that you're passionate about that you
enjoy
and then you can be like all right cool
now that we've taken that box
let's now turn my attention to kind of
helping other people because if you try
and do the helping other people without
feeling feeling the passion you end up
like burning out and yeah ultimately
it's not like that is
such a good analogy and i can literally
visually see it
it makes so much sense imagine imagine
trying to put everyone's mask on yours
is not on you're literally running out
of oxygen you can do more when you are
at 100 i always say that it's in the
book i'm like you can't give the world a
hundred percent when you yourself don't
know what that looks like for you and
when i took that two months off the
internet to write my book and focus on
my degree i couldn't do it
i couldn't do it and i will never try
and do it i will never try and show up
when i haven't yet showed up for me
and i know that that can sound a bit
selfish and i'm good i'm glad it does
because you should be selfish with your
mental health with what your needs are
before you try and give to the world
because then you'll go resentful
okay you'll grow resentful like imagine
you put all those masks on everybody
else and there's no more left for you
yeah you're not going to be feeling the
greatest because you're going to be like
what about what about me like who
who's the doctor for the doctor
right that kind of thing i just think um
find find your passion make sure make
sure you feel alive
yeah that's very much the vibe i got um
so i i did an interview with chrissy
chella who um had that book over there
um do do this for you oh yes i think i
watched um a clip
so she's she's great um and she's also
very very much like mission focused to
try and kind of empower women to take
better care of their health and be more
confident that kind of stuff similar to
your kind of vibes um and she was saying
that as well like you know she wakes up
at five in the morning which is amazing
wow and then um kind of between 5 a.m
and 10 a.m those are her hours for her
she like goes to the gym does the
training does her
commute all that kind of stuff so that
when she goes to work she can then show
up fully for the mission yeah but
her needs come first still at the end of
the day yeah i feel like that's like a
really great way of
because i think often there is this like
a lionization of the martyred of the
motto like oh this person is giving so
much of themselves that they've killed
themselves in the pursuit of this like
goal that's like okay but this is not
very sustainable no no that's why i was
saying it um
earlier about the fact that you
you need to
you need to be able to make sure that
you yourself
know why you're doing something and
there's a book start with a why right
you've got to start with a why because
if if you're if your mission and your
purpose are kind of like aimless and you
just do it because you've been told to
do it you'll lose momentum and i say
this to students as well about choosing
your degree for example right because
people always ask me this question how
do you know what the right degree to
choose is blah blah and i'm like
when your parents have like told you
what you had to study or society tells
you this is the right thing to study
yeah okay great you're gonna apply
you're gonna get into uni you're gonna
you're gonna do well in this first few
weeks it's gonna be great then that
essay crisis is gonna hit
and let me tell you what's gonna keep
you going when those moments arrive is
your passion for the thing caring about
oh my god i really want to understand
history and my place in the world
oh you have to get through this essay
right that that little thing then keeps
you going like i love my degree it's
just a hard day
now i hate in your degree
plus having the crisis and having to go
through the lectures
it's going to be a pretty difficult road
so i always try to say if you can
because i know that there are people who
are in situations where they don't have
a choice right this is what you study
because it's what we've always done
that's what gets the money and that's
the end of discussion but if you have
the choice
and you're able to exercise it you
better do it because not a lot of people
have that yeah so you better use that
privilege when you have it nice um
so
changing gears a little bit we've talked
a little bit about purpose i'm very
interested to hear thoughts about goals
okay because i've been
i don't know i'm quite anti-goals okay
so my so my theory and goals is that a
goal is like a fine if it's like it it
sort of gives you a direction um
but then
i find it helpful to just like forget
about the goal
because
the way i think of it is like it's it's
not really about the destination it's
far more about the journey yeah as miley
cyrus says it's the climb and you know
one of the things that i can do
uh kind of day-to-day
that will
help make my life more fulfilling or
more more more meaningful and more
impactful
without really thinking about like the
destinations i'm trying to get to it's
just
interesting i might have to disagree
because
because um
so you're trying to make your life
better trying to like
put systems in place that can help make
it easier like what you're saying like
day to day right but also
the thing with goals is they don't lock
you into anything right and i speak
about that in my book when i'm talking
about the goal setting systems that i
use they don't have to lock you into
anything like you if your goals lock you
into something you're doing it wrong
they need to be adjustable they need to
be able to change depending on the
context you can't be like the goal is to
be a cheater at harvard and then a
pandemic hits what do you do now we just
give up on the harvard dream no you have
to adjust to your circumstances and your
situation financial pandemic whatever it
is so i think that your goals
they shouldn't be locking you in they
should be something that you can adapt
and doing them regularly helps as well
so being like oh i have to do this one
thing and that's what my life is driven
towards
already you can see where the floors are
in that but every every month or every
two months people do tend to do three
months quarterly whatever it may be
every month or so
what season am i in what prioritize what
do i want to prioritize right now and
then having something you're working
towards because for example saving
like imagine just saving and there's no
goal that you're saving for when that
nando's takeaway temptation comes up
you're gonna get it but if you have a
rough idea like oh i roughly want to
save for my first deposit for my home
and i need 30 grand or something
in the next three years it means that
every year i need to save 10 which means
that in six months five which means this
month i could there's rice at home so
like it kind of an analogy no i love it
it kind of helps but i can agree with
you about the idea of the things that
are permanent nothing should ever be
permanent i don't care whether it's
marriage whether it's a home whether
it's even your degree or your job
nothing should ever because you're
evolving human you're multifaceted your
your emotions change your goals change
whatever it may be but i think to not
have
goals at all i can i
i struggle to see where the motivation
will come from
because like you could wake up every day
and decide
i don't know you just wake up every day
and then you're just doing what
i don't get it okay so if if i think
back to when i started the youtube
channel yeah um people are like what are
your goals for the channel and i think
generally what people are expecting is
some kind of number that i i want to hit
10k subs i want to hit whatever okay and
my philosophy on this was always like
i don't care about the number i just
want to make one video one one video
every week if i can just make one video
a week then that's all good see me
that's a goal okay yeah so maybe you can
say the same thing we're just kind of
using different i completely understand
what you're saying about like oh it
doesn't need to be if i don't hit a
million by the end of 2020 okay yeah
input goals versus outcome goals okay so
well one video a week is an input goal
that's 100 within my control okay
whether my video gets 10 000 views or
not is broadly outside of my control
yeah
so
with with that in mind
what's your what's your stance on output
goals
or our outcome goals rather
oh it's tricky it's tricky yeah it's
tricky because i can see i can see why
people would need them because they're
like oh this idea of the million
subscribers right that's what's going to
be driving me whereas for me i'm more
like you in the sense of why don't we
just think about the systems that we're
going to have and if that if it so
happens that you get the million
fair enough if it's like even with
graduating like my mom
i mean starting to sound like she
doesn't expect anything off me but she
did think i was gonna graduate but she
didn't necessarily care what i graduated
with yeah like there was no if it's not
a first class don't bother she was like
if you enjoy your time you learn stuff
you put yourself out there you raise
your hand in class you actually immerse
yourself in this oxford experience and
you own it as your own for me and her
i'd reach the goal like the moment i
finished my exams i closed my laptop
because obviously i was at home
i walked downstairs to like a party
like my mom was there was we didn't even
know my results yet did he even send off
did the computer crash i don't know but
i finished yeah and that was what we
cared about so i can see what you're
saying and maybe actually i live my life
avoiding the
output goals like the big strong things
but you still need something
like
it's like a to-do list we all we all
like what i say we all i love it to do
this because when you take it off you
just feel like imagine being like your
to-do list is in your head and it
doesn't matter as long as you wake up
today yeah right it's gonna be like you
could just spend the whole day just on
netflix yeah
so i don't know i find it tricky to see
how you could live
without any type of goals sure yeah
maybe maybe maybe the discussion is
what's the version of goals yeah no i
think i i think it is that because like
i i have loads of goals but they're all
like
broadly input goals that are within my
control yeah that's okay too yeah i
don't think i don't think it has i don't
think people need to put pressure on
themselves to be like
if if i finish law school i've got to be
a lawyer now
who said who what if you i have a friend
like right now and won't say his name i
don't know if he cares me to say this
but i have a friend who's doing medicine
and he literally has no desire to
practice it
he just enjoyed learning it yeah he's
someone to be honest
he's going to be a doctor by the time
january arrives and we're i'm so excited
for him like i can't wait to help him
plan this graduation party and the fact
that he doesn't want to be a doctor
now let's figure out what you want to do
i don't think the degree's a waste yeah
in my eyes like i don't think the
ultimate like this goal is only achieved
if you then become a doctor
and i want to raise my kids like that
okay so so continuing like because i'm
i'm i'm really curious about you about
your thoughts on the on this gold stuff
so would you
would you set the goal of
get into harvard or would you set a goal
of
apply to harvard with the best
application i can i can do
okay that is that is that's really good
really good stuff there have you
mine personally which i don't know if
it's gonna contradict what i've said
would be the getting in okay the getting
in would be one thing staying in is
another and the graduating is another
okay i would split them into three yeah
whereas i feel like other people would
put the getting and staying in and
graduating is like one thing and the
goal falls apart if one element is not
there but for me the getting in is like
oh my god like and this genuinely
happened we
had a party for the getting in when i
finished the exams at the party and then
now the graduation you saw in the garden
like it was genuinely three elements and
there's gonna be another one because
there's they're doing in person at
harvard so we go again but um and that's
that's great that's okay so
i don't know if that answers your
question but i will split it into rather
than the applying part but even though i
still celebrate that as well because i
have lots of students that come up to me
like i applied for oxford got the
interview and i didn't end up getting in
i'm like hello
you still got the interview like that is
amazing right so i think it depends on
the individual and how they want to
break it down but for me if i was
looking at that mba situation
the getting in
is one part of the
situation then the actual enjoying it
staying in if my mental health is not
doing well when i'm there if it's not
what i enjoy i'm gonna leave but it
doesn't take away from the fact that i
got it and then if i end up making it to
graduation my god that's like a whole
other thing
just basically i guess find ways to
throw as many parties as you can
that's how i live life no i mean that
makes a lot of sense and the way like
motivation is sustained is through these
like little successes and the more you
can celebrate the successes along the
way the more motivation there is and
it's kind of fun and life is good and
and you don't discriminate within them
like i said when i walked down those
stairs after finishing the last exam in
oxford the party was already happening
and my family would not have treated
that party differently had there have
been ended up being a fail in the
grading whatever yeah they that party
still has its moment so i think it's
really respecting each part of the
process as well if if you're gonna go
down the route of focusing on your input
goals you might as well do it properly
um yeah does that make sense but there's
still goals yeah they obstacles i think
yeah
my thing if i don't believe in goals is
actually like a semantic thing i do
believe in goals just generally goals in
my control and input goals yeah cause
like you know i'm i'm working on a book
at the moment and
when i
there's like two different goals that i
have had at different points one of them
is i want this to hit the new york times
best seller list wow and the other one
is i want to write a book i'm proud of
oh and when i think about that first one
it sucks all of the motivation out of
writing this book yeah that's it just
feel safe
because
like because see what you're doing there
is you've placed
you've placed the importance or
the success of the book in the new york
times and like what other people have
decided as opposed to what i've decided
about it whereas where is like if the
book is great and let's just say it hits
the uk and does amazing the uk but
people are really using it and they are
they are opening that thing they're
highlighting there they're putting
different bookmarks they're like
printing it out telling their friends
sending quotes sharing it
versus it like maybe it hits the best
times because people just buy it but
they never read it what would you prefer
it just having the title of bestseller
or it being like an actual piece of
people's lives that's that's the thing
that i want do you know what i mean and
also for yourself right like i we
haven't this book is not out yet my book
is literally not out yet but i look at
it with such pride like it is my
genuinely my baby like i've read it and
reread it and read it and reread it and
i will share it with people that
obviously in my circle that i can and
i'm so proud of it now now what happens
next once it's out is so out of my
control that i haven't even i haven't
even thought about okay where it what's
gonna happen to it once it's out because
whether or not it does well or not like
i still wrote that thing that's still
one year of my time of my thoughts of my
life in there and i'm still so proud of
it hence the book launch party is
happening
two days after it's out right because
you know how the family works now might
as well party exactly imagine if i was
to wait only i'll only do a party when
it hits new york's best seller right and
then imagine it never does yeah and then
it's like what so
was yeah the book is gonna be sitting
there like what did i do like i still
came out i still i was here and it's
still helpful for the few people that
read it and it doesn't deserve a party
because it didn't
hit certain numbers like
but also i get it i get it you can't
just be like as long as it's out there
i'm happy because it's still also a
business it's still also there are a
number the people involved in this are
people who you know i get it you also
need to be realistic i think i also
avoid too much of that conversation
too much like i need to find a better
balance and it's one of my goals for
2022 is to kind of
be more
businessy business-minded and less
detached from it because i think i've
been so
put off from it for so long and i just
don't know why and i think it's i think
it's the reasons of why i began the
whole channel right like to not think of
it as like it's a brand or all those
words make me so uncomfortable and i'm
like why i need to tap into that look
into that and for so long i was like oh
it's so good like i just don't care
about it like yeah i'm so great it's
like no actually like that is not what
the version of empowerment that you're
trying to build is about you want your
young girls to be financially literate
you want them to be as knowledgeable
about what's happening with their
mortgage as their husbands are like
they're equals in this you want them to
be in the labor market like you don't
you're not just trying to say
empowerment in education it's in every
aspect so for me to shy away from the
business aspect when it's happening it's
not as though i'm at home thinking about
starting a channel i'm like oh it's got
to hit this many numbers and we've got
to get make this much money it's already
happening so why am i avoiding it that's
something i've got to like battle with
myself so i can't blame you for thinking
about the new york times bestseller
but also i wouldn't want you to be lost
in that and lose the fact that you've
just written a book
like don't lose this chasing just this
because imagine i'm not saying it's
gonna happen but imagine that never
happens does that mean
you never celebrate your book no exactly
yeah that's like that that kind of
difference between those two different
goals like a book i'm proud of versus
book that does well on the stats
basically i think that
that difference is my philosophy on goal
setting which is that the write a book
i'm proud of to me feels like a much
more motivating goal when i sit down and
think okay i'm going to try and write a
book and proud of it it feels good um as
like a goal to shoot for do you think
the two are not compatible or something
like are you thinking if you wrote a
book that you were completely proud of
like you put everything into it
that it might not be a great book or are
you like should we write for the new
york times bestseller and that might be
a book you're not proud of like do you
think the two can't exist together i
think they can exist together and i
would love for them to exist together
but i i just sort of think of it as like
whenever the goal shifts too much it's
like for example if i make a video and
my mindset during the video is i really
want this to be the best video i can
make versus i really wanted to hit a
million views it's like it might
actually be the same video at the end of
the day but the way i've approached it
when i'm thinking about my own
authenticity and making video i'm proud
of is so different to the way i approach
it trying to get a viral video
well i think in my personal opinion
if you are to make a book you're proud
of because you have to think it's not
just by luck and because you're really
good at numbers that you know how to
make a channel grow
people also are buying into your
personality they like the way that you
look at life like you are like quite a
unique person i think and like just the
way that you do things and everything
and it's quite like captivating right so
so i can't see how you
simply focusing on writing a book that
you are proud of how you don't see that
that or automatically follows with the
bestseller because to me
you doing it your way your complete
authentic weight just because of how you
think and
look at the way you're doing youtube
right you're setting the pace and like
you're setting that bar so imagine you
actually just do the book the way you
want and forget that the algorithms of
best sellers and whatever it may be
because yeah it might have worked in the
past but what if you're on the cusp of a
new way and then you're always going to
be what we all follow so i think you
trusting your instinct and doing it your
way
to me is an automatic new york time
that's why i'm asking like do you think
that do you think is this one yeah yeah
no i think hopefully hopefully one will
lead to the other but also i'm trying
not to think of the hopefully i'm just
like because if you went the other way
around yeah i don't see how that would
go that would go well because you might
study like okay what are the ten latest
bestsellers that have what was the same
and did they include that
it's like reverse engineering sucking
the life out of it kind of yeah
and i think those moments that you're
gonna be
writing
two in the morning or whatever where you
just can't put the laptop down and you
actually turn your phone off chinese
takeaway and you're just like i think
that's going to be like your best
chapters you know what i mean yeah so um
fingers crossed
yeah but it's a good question though
which which way
for me i think we all know which way i'm
going to go
i do i have not looked at anything like
i did not study my market and i don't
know if that's a good thing i'm not sure
if i'm proud of that because i also
think that success is when preparation
miss opportunity right so
did i prepare the best i don't know
because i really did not
look into anything it was just i'm
writing from my heart and i hope that
this resonates with someone and let's
see what happens
so
maybe in the next book if i do a next
book i might try
that approach and i could produce
something even better or what who knows
it's just different ways to approach it
yeah what are um what are empowered life
goals
empowered life goals so empowered life
goals are essentially
long-term goals that you might have but
they are
driven and are embedded in everything
that makes you feel whole everything
that makes you feel like you are living
your true authentic life and you're
truly empowered and by that i mean
everything you're doing is your choice
or the majority of it some things we
really can't control but the majority of
it is your choice you wake up feeling
like okay
i'm designing my life the way that i
want it to be and it's something that
it's it's it's it's within your control
it also has a self self belief self
confidence that it's all centered around
you so empowered life goals would be
things that you don't you're not making
decisions based on what you think is the
right thing to do like oh i've got to go
be a banker or i've got to go get
married at 25 because that's what like
my grandma says right it is actually i
want to travel and i want to have kids
when i'm 35 yeah and that's one of my
goals like i do want a family but don't
rush me i want my family at this stage
or actually i want to go and study law
after medicine right like you want to
feel
completely and totally
you i just don't like
one life on earth and
you're gonna have that time
shaped by other people and you're living
for other people and you're trying to
please other people and it's like we
don't know what happens after that's a
whole different podcast and a whole
different conversation right but let's
just pretend for a second that we don't
know so let's just cut that thought off
for now and this is it this is all we've
got
and it's like there's no do-over and you
spent it worrying i always think man if
we could calculate the amount of hours
we've spent worrying and doubting
ourselves and i want if we got that time
back i wonder what we could do different
i just wonder but yeah empowered life
goals are just
things that
are entirely driven by your passion
purpose
the things that you like the things that
you enjoy and they don't always have to
be purposeful i don't ever not
everything that i do has a purpose to it
okay there are some things that i just
do because i just like to do it this is
just what i just enjoy and that's okay
it doesn't always have to have like a a
bigger outcome or a bigger goal to it it
can just be oh i'm doing this because i
like it like i'm going to take
zumba classes there's nothing else to it
apart from i just want to go and dance
zumba so empowered life goals are
things that are entirely centered around
the things that make you happy and yes
yes life is not always happy sometimes
you have to encounter hardship and
different things but if you have the
choice like i keep saying
why would you choose
the bad things why
nice
um what's your pyramid method oh my god
so the pyramid method and i don't know
where i got this wrong i don't know if i
read about it or if i made it up i'm not
sure but what i do when i'm looking at
setting my goals i i visualize it as a
pyramid right so i'm looking at it as
what is the thing at the top for this
season for this moment in my life okay i
want to write a book that's what i want
to do i really want to write a book and
i want it to be out when i graduate
don't know why this is what i wanted and
that's okay sometimes there's no
reasoning to it but it makes sense to
you i want it to come out by the time
i've graduated in 2021 cool so you put
that at the top of your pyramid like
it's in the top square then everything
else under that pyramid the things the
structures that make that pyramid stand
up tall proud and it's the biggest and
the baddest and the greatest that's
what's going to matter now these are
your systems so what you slot in here is
what's going to uplift that goal so okay
cool so if we want to do in a year we
want a book and that book has to be 60
000 words it means that we need to write
thirty thousand in the next six months
so then the two slots underneath are
going to be thirty thousand thirty
thousand then either side's gonna be how
am i gonna make sure i get to that
thirty thousand okay so it might mean
that we need to make sure this month
we're writing one thousand words and
then if it's 1 000 words okay it means
that today i need to do five hours of
work whatever it may be so it's a way of
like breaking down things to bite-size
intricate chunks that you can see from a
day-to-day perspective because sometimes
i think when people set goals it's so
far away over there that it feels
unattainable and it feels so out of
reach and then before you know it the
years ended there's no book because it's
so overwhelming that you just never
start so i like to break it down to this
week what does this week look like and
that's the bottom of your pyramid that's
right here what does this week look like
in order to make sure in one year that
goal is reached and that is how i
approach everything almost i break it
down too and also sometimes
your goals might not be something that's
feasible for you not because you can't
do it because you're not good enough for
it it's actually just nearly impossible
considering what else you're doing like
you just don't have the physical time
and breaking it down in that way you can
actually see oh it's 500 words a day
that takes three hours
actually i'm at school that time i can't
do it right now so maybe you'll extend
your goal to write the book in two years
time and now it's more manageable so the
perimeter system for me
is
looking at the structures that i'm using
and making sure
that the systems
can accommodate the goal
because you can't have a goal that's
systemless
it doesn't work no that's true it
doesn't work
i mean it's okay so um one of one of the
things that stops people that makes
people shy away from goals is fear of
failure
and fear of rejection you have a whole
you have a whole thing about this oh
well what's your what's your thing about
rejection oh you know how they have
their love languages yeah and the five
they need to add one for me about
rejection and failure i'm like that's
your love language oh this is me like
talk to me
listen
failure is another chance to try again
and i really mean this when i say
failure is like my fuel like i i i
thrive from it because it's like okay
now i've just gained insight into
something and i have this pebble uh
analogy that i heard it was so good and
i just kept it it's like being on a
pebble and it's full of like a pebble
beach of you know pebbles i don't know
what else to say pebbles and someone
tells you there is a hundred million
that's obviously gonna change your life
a hundred million dollar check under one
of these pebbles go
the first thing you do is turn over the
pebble you're standing next to an eye's
not there
you're not gonna go home no you're not
there's a hundred million on this beach
that's yours you're gonna keep turning
these bubbles over and as you're turning
each of these pebbles over guess what
you're gaining information about where
that money isn't okay and you're going
to say okay that section over there i've
checked it out it's not over there and
you're just going to now put a little
method in place i've looked at the i've
looked at it
until you find it you're not going to
give up yeah so
yeah that's just that's just what i
think um
yeah
like the the the chapter is about this
idea that rejection is redirection
what do you mean by that
so rejection's redirection so when you
get rejected from something
you're gonna you're gonna still live
like that is the reality you're not
gonna die from this okay when you're
rejected from university when you reject
from your job you're still gonna be here
so now that we know you're going to be
here
there needs to be a next step and the
next step is redirection like you're not
going to stand still you're not
that door has closed
it it's inevitable another one has to
open now what that other one is going to
be that is going to be how we based on
how we approach it how we frame it we're
going to enter this as a new opportunity
so it's a redirection it's like
something greater is coming
and why do i say it's greater because
you've just you just gone through an
experience that's made you stronger it's
giving you information it's you're a
different person now like when your next
moment comes
it's redirection like there is nothing
else to say apart from you were going to
go this way
you can't now so you're going that way
you're going to make the best of it
because that's what happens you've got
to live in the moment of what you're at
and what you're doing
and if you get rejected from it live in
the moment of that and give that a full
chance so that's what i mean failure is
another chance to try again
is you
turning that pebble over the money's not
there now you know where else to try now
you know where it's not and it's as
important to know what you don't want to
do or where you shouldn't be as is to
know what you want to do and i look at
it like this right your ultimate
happiness is like here
whatever that means is here and every
time that something doesn't quite go the
right way or you get rejected or fail
whatever you're just like ticking off
you're just like literally getting
closer and closer and closer and closer
to finding yourself to finding what you
like knowing your boundaries knowing
what excites you all this stuff you're
just getting closer and closer and for
me that's why i celebrate leaving that
job because now i know what i don't want
to do it's definitely that one
now let's let's go again
yeah it's great it's great stuff
one of the
so one of the things that we teach on um
when i teach like uh people how to start
youtube channels and stuff is the idea
of having an accountability buddy
and i saw that you talk a lot about
accountability partners as well what
what's the what is an accountability
partner for you and and what's there
what's the benefit oh you really really
read this book
okay accountability partners what i call
them like your empowerment circle so
accountability partners is how everyone
knows it but in our world we call it
empowerment circle so it's having people
there that are invested in you they're
invested in you
what you're doing
seeing your growth and seeing you
succeed so that when you might be
doubting yourself or having that moment
where imposter syndrome creeps in
there is another version of you someone
who's holding you ideas who gives like a
aaaa let's not be drastic and delete the
channel because today you didn't get the
views you wanted like give it a week
let's draw come back to drawing board
and go again so having an empowerment
circle or an accountability partner is
someone who can
hold you accountable to what you said
you want for yourself until you
obviously are like seriously my goals
have changed it's not what i wanted more
fine but if it is what you want and
you're having a bad moment
i'm telling you now you need people
around you who are invested in that
because
if you don't you can talk yourself out
of anything i think we've all seen it
you know you've got to wake up for the
gym at 6 00 am you will talk yourself
out of it and you'll stay in bed you
know you need to walk past that shop and
just go home and cook you will buy that
food like we all have those moments and
having an accountability partner is kind
of like
it's kind of like having a parent
there before you spend your money every
time and have to explain why you're
doing this amazon order you know like it
just gives you that other layer of
yeah let me think twice before before i
do that thing that might be not in my
best interest so for me having my
empowerment circle is is being able to
go to them and say i really want to
write a book but i'm feeling nervous
about it and then they're like you want
to write a book call it this like let's
let's start fleshing out and they give
me hype like they hype me up and help me
see that vision bigger and also when i'm
like guys i can't do it i want to quit
and there were moments i wanted to quit
my channel there were moments that i was
like no i'm done and my sister was like
no no no no remember why we started this
and then like they helped you like come
back to that moment and i'm so grateful
for that because
it was so close when did you want to
quit oh my gosh how much time do we have
i wanted to quit when i was at uni
because people were sometimes not kind
that is an aspect of it like you would
assume because this is you know
something that's so
student-driven and so mission-driven
that everyone would love it and support
it and that's not always the case people
didn't like what i was doing and
i wouldn't i don't want to use the word
bullied because it's so it's such a big
and loaded term but people were unkind
and i was just like man i just want to
be a student like i just want to be at
uni and be able to go to a party and be
like hi i'm v and not someone be like
you're v and then already they've got a
judgement or already they there there's
some motive behind it that you don't
know or whatever like i was starting to
find that difficult and there was a time
i'd walk past like
my college and walk past a room and i
can hear them watching my video
like laughing oh yeah and i was like oh
this is a beginning though you have to
think i started at uni
so they watched it go from zero to where
it is now it's not like i got there and
i was doing it and then like have to
respect it because it's what i do i was
at the beginning where it's still it's
still like if you say something that
might trigger me i could stop it's still
at the beginning stages and i almost
stopped
wow
almost stopped
what kept you going my sister my mom my
accountability they were absolutely
empowerment so absolutely not gonna have
that yeah and if i'd given a good reason
of i no longer enjoy it it's causing me
to feel unhappy they'll be like you know
what fair enough like the job like you
gotta go it's time we support it but
because of other people you still like
what you're doing but because they've
laughed at you
and everybody was so sorry and that's
what got me i was like keep the same
energy
keep the same energy if you're going to
be mad about it be mad about it forever
don't be mad about it and i'll be the
first in the comments you go v as if as
if
you don't know what happened last
semester
it was a whole situation
i hate that i really hate that like you
can see someone is enjoying what they're
doing and they're doing it for a reason
for a reason that is bigger than all of
us like we we're trying to help and they
were in the that's what keeps getting me
they were in the videos in the beginning
they were helpful talking to the
students guys hey guys hey guys now now
you don't like it
questionable
do you get much hate these days
not to my face
i i don't know what happens behind the
scenes and i definitely don't read any
of these uh gossip guru things or tattle
things i don't know i don't read them i
don't read them at all i i found out
what they were when we had this
sleepover at oxford with all the study
tubular out there people i was like what
is that like what are you on about
tattle what does that mean
i went on there
and i said yeah my sister was like she
was like you better stop because i i
read i thought oh
yeah that's interesting
is that what you saw and i was like
refreshing
for a week i was in this tattle
the hole yeah and i was like yeah same i
was on it for about a week as well
before i realized okay yeah and the
thing is once you start hearing it
you're like i need to hear more and then
and then i i saw myself go on my channel
i was like hey guys
i i wasn't hey guys because someone said
it was too loud yeah i thought wait a
minute i think i put it in the book like
if you're going to change yourself based
on what per se
someone's going to say today v you're
too loud tomorrow they'll say you're
talking too quiet someone's gonna say
your voice is too squeaky before you
know you're on your channel being like
hey guys we're gonna like you don't even
know what to do anymore no can't do that
like
yeah
you just have to give yourself a chance
in this world man
yeah retweet
um final thing i wanted to touch on was
you're like surprisingly open about
talking about money
yeah
that's quite yeah um
why is that shocking
because most people aren't
and it's still like a taboo thing yeah
um and like i'm very open to talking
about money and people find to find that
weird yeah i'm always a bit like baffled
why it's so weird like why it's like a
cabbage thing to talk about money okay
so
here's my thing about money right when
when everything on youtube started
happening like i was just so open with
my friends and family just because it
was like oh my god
this is crazy we've just gone from
mcdonald's money right i was making like
four pounds 95 an hour or something like
this and then now you're like oh my god
there's a few hundred pounds in my
account and that's shocking like we're
all like
what so i was just open to talking about
money with my friends and family from
the beginning because we just could not
believe our eyes like what for one
minute they're asking me giving you how
much for one minute that would have been
how many shifts at work for us so it was
just blowing our minds
then i got onto the internet and i don't
know it was just weird like
you couldn't really talk about it
because it felt like rude
like it felt it felt like and i just
didn't get it because obviously i always
knew i know what my mom makes what my
sister makes my friends like it's not a
secret if you work at the kfc with me i
know what we're wrong like whereas in
this world it is such it's so in the
book i was so
i really wanted to talk about it but i
also knew like there were still these
like social limitations like i couldn't
be like so today this is how much i made
in this hour so i was like okay
i can put some distance between it like
i can say
when youtube began in the first two
years yeah this is how it was going and
that's because obviously that's not
where we're at now but i can say okay
this is how it was going in this is
these are numbers which i still think
are crazy right i went from something
like there was a a you just a brand that
i was working with and when i befriend
management they were like yeah i'll be
like
we've stretched our budgets and like we
can give you 200 for like a minute's
work and you know you know that's and i
was like oh my god i'm so grateful thank
you so much and i was so over the moon
that i had management yeah and like
three months later the same brand the
money was in the thousands
and i was like
i haven't grown that much
nothing has really changed here and that
made me angry because it was like so
once again
a lack of knowledge and knowing means
that you just can get ripped off all the
time yeah when like why is me having
management means now you can pay
times 10.
like how does that make any sense so
in the book i discuss like
adsense fees things like that in the
first year of youtube because i feel
like okay it's fair enough it's far away
yeah yeah it's far enough away but also
it's still mind-boggling like even when
i we're my friends because obviously i
mean now with friends and family and
everybody it's just like okay they know
they get it so now they they still have
those prices in their mind as well
because i just don't talk to him about
it anymore now because it's i don't know
there's just no point anymore we get it
they know we're amazed by it it's done
whatever so when they read that they're
still like whoa
so i was like okay this is still
something good to share because it still
shows you how drastic the jump is and i
just couldn't believe it like i'm a
university student making thousands from
being on the internet so what what were
the figures from years one and two
so years one and two i think there was a
video that i did on youtube and it got
like
2 000 piles or something in that month
because i think it just did really well
and then the brand managements were
getting management deals for like four
thousand here five thousand hey and i
was like first year bloody hell that's
pretty good
no seriously because in that first year
that's when i was
blowing up yeah right so they managed me
when i had like
i think they came to me and had
15 000 subscribers or something and then
within four months we were like we hit
20 30 40 50k so in that time i guess
when they're pitching they were like
she's gaining 10 000 subscribers every
month or every week you better do it now
while you know what i mean so
they were getting amazing deals and i
was like
what in the i literally went from my
mcdonald's paycheck to this
there was no there was no gradual to it
whatsoever and that blew my mind what's
that like how does that change
change your perspective if at all
the good thing is like i keep saying the
friends and family at home
nothing has really changed in their
world so it's still the same so we still
have those conversations and i'll still
do budgeting talks with them and like i
can't be like well it's only a hundred
it's like no it's not only a hundred
that was how many hours work for you
i still need to be in tune with that but
also
i can't be on the internet like guys i
gotta get pot noodle today because i
don't have to let's be realistic here
like i hate when people pretend when you
know you know you're in a better
situation like you
you don't need to talk about port noodle
right now you know if you really wanted
to get a table you could order it and
that wouldn't do anything for you
so i
it was tricky
but
my audience are amazing like whenever
especially disney right like i work with
disney a lot which i mean we know
disney's got deep pockets right it might
my audience know that and whenever i
post like a disney ad they do the best
like you could get 500 comments on a
disney account because they're like
supporting like oh my god oh damn hold
on you got the yeah yeah they're like
get more yeah
they love it that's like
pretty unusual like most audiences will
be like oh you're a sellout no no you're
like hell yeah
yeah they're like you deserve this like
absolutely you've been doing this you've
been working hard and i think they know
the journey as well yeah this is new and
the first in my family to be seeing this
kind of money right i actually think my
mom was like i said oh my god let mom
give me 20 pounds
and now i'm like oh my gosh i could make
my mom's salary in under a few months
like that blows my mind right so now i
know there is a responsibility that
comes with that like i will always help
my family when i can they and they don't
they don't um
i don't know what the right word is they
don't
oh what's the word it's not it's not
abuse
expect it no like they don't exploit
that they don't like they wouldn't be
like okay now that you're making some
money you've got to take care of
everything no like it takes a lot for me
to like mom let me take your winter coat
shopping she will still be like should i
just go to primark and like let's find
one in the sale i'm like mommy
whichever one yeah exactly it's like
i've got this or if i i say to meet me
in town when i'm going home she'll
literally like i'm gonna get the bus i'm
like can i just order an uber uber's
expensive 20 pounds i'm like mom it's
okay like she's still in that space so i
don't think
there'd ever come a time where i could
lose touch of it yeah because it's
always around me but yeah i
i'm lucky that my audience are so
supportive of it
they don't skip ads
they love when a video is sponsored like
they do well my videos like i've never
had an issue with branded content or my
audience being like what are you doing
and because everything is all like 16th
is amazing my management they never
bring me anything that's not aligned so
if i do a deal it's always something
where my audience gets something out of
it
and they obviously never have to pay for
anything that i'm doing so for them it's
like wait she's got a brand deal and all
you have to view it and like it like
that's a literal have to do and we still
get to consume her content for free
online we still get to come to events
for free like all the empowered
empowered will never be a monetized or
charged thing
so for them it's like
what it was a comment and to to be
honest with you that is logical like i
don't get when people get hate but ads i
guess maybe if their audience feel like
you've you've grown our community and
now you've just stopped what we're doing
just for you to be doing ads and just
use the numbers for that like maybe
that's where they get annoyed whereas
for me i'm like if this ad is not if
it's not feeding in
does it make sense for example i'll work
with people like the civil service and
in the ad we will have a link that
people can go and apply for like help on
getting onto the fast stream for example
so i've definitely made money from
working with civil service but my
audience have been exposed to this thing
and they also get a link like nothing is
ever
unaligned in a line to whatever the word
is
yeah
do you
do you find that as you make more money
your goal posts for what a good amount
of money is shift no right because as
long as i have enough for what it did
yeah then it's five
okay
do you know what i mean so you're
thinking in terms of like oh you know
the channel's making x amount of revenue
this year and kind of next year kind of
be cool to like i don't know 2x 3x that
kind of stuff i feel like by now you
know yeah
that there is number one i don't have a
team right so like i mean i think what
you're doing here is so cool i think i
texted you about it like i
in 2022 will definitely be trying to
start thinking that way but
currently it is just me yes my
management is there but their job is
solely to go and get brand deals and my
job is to
keep the channel alive so that brand
deals can go on to something right but
there's no team that's like let's
analyze
stats or these are our financial goals
because there are people to feed right
like you have a team people who are
relying on making a salary here so like
you need this it's a whole operation
whereas this is just me
just me and my ideas there's no one else
so there's never been a deep dive into
this is the channel's like forever no
she's like oh this month i'm like oh yay
yeah that's a good number yeah that's
pretty because my rent's paid up front i
pay my rent up front yep my rent's paid
up front
what is it
what do you do with the cash
what do you mean like do you invest in
stuff or like okay so you see my friend
he's really great for this he was like v
you can't just have money sitting in the
bank like you need to do something with
it so i've got onto this thing called
it's the chest change name to circa 500
or something do you know what it used to
be called tick er t i k r okay something
like this it's really great it's all
about like being able to invest into
causes that help the world so it's
really nice so you can choose which kind
of investing you want to do and i've
chosen people and environment so every
month takes a few hundred out and it
goes in there and it's nice but that's
as far as i'm going and most of my
investment is my education right like
harvard i paid for myself
a scholarship
but that was really cool that i could
even do that like it was like okay we
didn't get the scholarship i guess yeah
we've got to go withdraw 27 grand and
just pay for this up front
and that's a really nice thing to do and
like the phd
i'm not super stressed about oh my god
gotta get scholarship if i get it great
if i don't
i guess we're gonna pay for it
disney disney so um yeah for me now it's
it's my investments i guess are in
things like
my education
the apartment which is
it is it's a really nice apartment it's
really great but for me i'm like why i
can live there so why would i not so
things like experiences traveling but
also this app investing in there and as
2022 comes financial literacy is what's
on my agenda and now sitting down and
talking with my accountant
talking maybe getting a financial
advisor and just chatting about okay
you can't just keep pretending that this
is just
la di da is just happening by chance
like it's happening let's track let's
invest let's
let's be more financially wise here and
also start to be business-minded as i
shift into like
my adulthood i suppose so
yeah and i think that that would be a
really interesting strand of content on
your channel like documenting the
journey of you
learning about financial literacy
exactly and it's going to be from
scratch and it's just going to
be it's like just a genuine journey of
okay guys
i know how to accept that
as much as i love what i'm doing
it it also comes with
this side of things that brands are
gonna want to work with you because they
they also love what you stand for and
and my audience understands and i love
that because it'd be so hard for them to
be like but you're supposed to be doing
this because you care so how is this is
there an ad in the middle yeah it's like
does that take away from the fact that
the content that you still got after
that one minute was still helpful no and
they really really get that and i i'm
lucky really lucky because i know it can
be different audiences can be quite
touchy about that but
not mine
i have a few kind of rapid fire
questions
if that's all right oh that's
nerve-wracking um i mean the the
questions are rapid the answers don't
have to be but yeah um so
what what advice would you give to your
younger self
the question i asked everybody
what advice did i give to my younger
self
i always say this
but i don't know if it's so true because
would everything that happened that
happened i don't know but to my younger
self i'd have told myself
to start being more audacious
sooner no what do you mean like right
now there's no goal that's out of my
reach there's nothing that i would say
maybe don't maybe don't think about that
like oh everyone do
phd like don't think stanford no that's
not going to work or you want to do a
speech don't think the u.n like there's
nothing that is too big and i feel like
there was a time when i was younger even
though my mom was supportive like i keep
saying she said lead and i'll follow so
if i didn't choose something that was
really really high then it wasn't going
to happen right so i wish that i had
started to
see myself as i do now a lot younger
especially when i was trying to like
unlearn all of this you're an orphan
stuff which doesn't even make sense like
number one i don't know why the robin
culture does that but if you lose a
father then you are an orphan but it's
like that doesn't make sense because you
still have a mom but it becomes with all
that like gender inequality stuff they
don't view the mom is significant enough
that your status changes based on your
father so i wish that i'd unlearned that
what i'd inherited from that orphan like
that's what you are and they treat you
that way and being so nervous and like
never really like speaking up
wish i'd learned that sooner but also
you know
that's life yeah um who's had the
biggest influence in your career would
you say gosh i don't know i guess i
would say
really really powerful women like oprah
winfrey or michelle obama's you know
people like that i think really inspire
me because they've made names for
themselves based on themselves
and even though someone could argue but
michelle her husband was the president
it's like yeah he was but have you ever
heard her referred to as barack obama's
wife
like you don't really ever hear that no
she's her own exactly it's michelle
obama yeah and he's like oh yeah she's
married to barack but it's never oh
he's a wife and i really like that i
like when women obviously malala like i
mean you know she's just
amazing i think
watching her as my friend is is like i
get a front row seat at the world's
greatest show she just navigates
everything with such grace
she's so
powerful and assertive and does it in
such a way that's just so
ah it's just so good and she never has
to raise her voice he never has to do
all of these traditionally
um
traditionally masculine things that a
lot of women tend to have to do to be
seen or heard she's just her and you
will listen like that room will go quiet
for her and i love that so i think in my
career people like that have definitely
influenced me a lot to just be my
authentic self and exist within my story
and find power in that and not feel like
oh my god i have to go and make a
gimmick out of this or i have to go and
jazz it up for it to be special it's
like no
this is this is what happened i can't i
can't go back and undo it so what i'm
gonna do is celebrate it and you're
gonna hear about it love it
what's one tip for someone looking for
success
oh gosh
i guess i would say
understand what success looks like for
you
because the moment that you think
it's
this formula or it looks this way
you're never going to reach it because
you're aspiring for someone else's
version of something and even when you
get there you will find that you won't
be happy okay the goalposts will keep on
moving and keep on changing so
the number one thing that has to be at
the forefront of everything is what is
your version of success your version of
success could be going to school
finishing uni
and then getting married having children
and then being a stay-at-home mom that
could be your absolute aspiration and
then that's what you want to do and
that's okay and when you've reached you
could be like i've got my three children
and i feel successful and for someone
else that could be their worst nightmare
they could be like i want to travel the
world build an empire be a ceo
own the company whatever it may be and
that's their version so figuring out
what it is
for you is a first step
and then
you go out and you start to do it you
start to ask for help get on linkedin if
you have to type in the job title you're
aspiring to do ask that person for a
coffee or go to your teacher do you know
anybody or you just now you start the
grafting but the first step is figuring
out what makes you happy
not what you think is supposed to make
you happy because that's a whole
different thing
but what actually makes you happy and
sometimes
you could think that's what it is you
can get there and it's not yeah it's
okay we pivot we maneuver we adjust we
keep going
what's your definition of success
my definition of success
is
for me to be
working with other change makers
in a space where i feel valued seen
where my ideas and my opinions are
contributing to something and we are
working on this mission for girls
education that is
that is just ah
on my travels when i was in zimbabwe and
i was talking to girls and orphanages or
visiting the schools and they were just
telling me like i just i just want to
learn
like i don't want to get married and i
know that's what's coming next month
like just seeing it live in the flesh
and knowing that could have been me i
think that is that is what drives me the
most is knowing if my mom hadn't been as
brave and strong as she is
managing to leave the uk to come here to
do what she did to set up and get us
over here i would have been the girls
i'm talking to so for me it's like nah
i just i want to work
in that and for me success
would be seeing that number decrease
130 million girls out of school
130 million that is
massive
so being able to know that that number's
decreasing
and that we're creating generational
change
yeah that would be success for me
what does the first and last hour of
your day normally look like oh my gosh
the first hour
that's in the morning that's my favorite
time honestly i love it i play music i
have really
nice happy music you know like soul
sister hey soul system that kind of
stuff like i'll just be singing i'm sure
my neighbors must think what is going on
in there i'll wake up shower
i have music blasting the whole time
um drink some water
have porridge
do my hair do some makeup put on a cute
outfit and then
go to my oh
to my office in the next room
and then i open the laptop and i emails
admin it's always my first thing respond
to the things that need to urgent
response
then after that it's
tackle the rest of the day nice as it
comes and the last hour what does that
look like the last hour i always to be
honestly i end up talking to my sister
like my mom and my sister we love a good
group chat called
we have a chat about how our day looked
i might read and then
that is it or sometimes i'll watch
something which is always dangerous
because if i watch something
i'm just gonna like fall asleep it's
gonna keep playing i don't sleep great
so i tried to keep my phone away from me
because that i think i learned that from
you i watched a video
where you
had your phone like charging somewhere
else yeah actual alarm clock game
changer yeah yeah which is crazy because
i was like
it's like oh buy an alarm clock
but i watched one of your videos and i
was like let me try this and i slept
so great
like when my phone is away from me i
sleep so well but yeah that's what the
last hour it could be a bad hour and i'm
watching something and i fall asleep to
that or switch to the family read a book
then go to bed nice
um what physical item so this is
something that's like maybe less than
100 pounds um do you think it's like
really underrated or the what physical
item couldn't you live without i think
my tripod oh okay yeah but that's
because of the line of work that i'm in
right my tripod enables me to have
freedom
like i can just go anywhere and i can do
it because i like to capture what i'm
doing i really enjoy that some people
find that strange to like leave your
life documenting it but
i like it and i also love doing it so my
tripod means that i don't have to
have people with me all the time yeah i
just have the clicker the tripod i can
put my camera on there on my phone on
there it's the same height as me i can
twist it turn it i go on holiday on my
own my entire photography's myself like
all that kind of stuff whereas before if
i didn't have it i always have to think
someone come out for dinner with me
someone come to shopping with me so i
can twirl and i don't have embarrassment
i set up the tripod i do my twirling i
do what i want to do like nothing really
phases me so my tripod gives me that
freedom to be able to do
those kinds of things without having to
think
companionship all the time
yeah i enjoy being alone so it allows me
to be alone it's very nice tripod is
that one yeah it's like predictable does
that like extend as high as you yeah not
not exactly but it's like about eye
level and i have a few of them at home
because sometimes it's annoying to like
twist and turn so i have that one for
the camera i have one for my phone and
and then i buy everyone this tripod yeah
like it's a gift that i give everybody
and they love it like they're always
like that's the best thing you gave me
literally that i i need to check out
that tripod yeah oh yeah it's really
really missing one of these things in my
life and i've had this one for like now
i think two years maybe and it hasn't
never broken so my tripod and that cost
like 20 pounds but it allows me to be
able to do
things on my own
um what book other than yours would you
recommend to everyone that is a really
good question now are we talking about
recommendation because it's an enjoyable
read or because it's helpful let's go
both
okay it's like one one for each so
something that i think is really really
helpful is a book by a person
called we should all be feminists
i don't want to say you're so
controversial right now but like the
book is still great
chimamanda chimamanda adichie and gozi
people are a bit annoyed at her right
now but that's different story but the
book is really great
we should all be feminist yes we should
all be feminists it's tiny it's like
this little book
that one and um the feminist manifesto
both by her tiny little books you could
read it in two hours for that
oh it's so good
talks she's writing a letter to her
friend about how to raise her baby girl
and she's like
please don't put these expectations
please don't use this language please
just let them and it just talks about
why feminism is important and how it's
not something that's like radical that
everyone just thinks about and it's not
this bad thing you're just literally
asking me to
equity and equality right like it's it's
just great so that one for being helpful
for i think everybody should read it and
then just a book that i enjoyed
educated oh yeah by tara i think that
book had me on edge there were some
moments because like
that really happened the skin was
peeling and i'm like oh the moment i'm
like no i'm crying like it had me in all
the fields and it's
michelle obama's favorite book too
i mean the the next question oh well
actually i'm i'm curious so if you
if you lost everything so all the
money's gone all the followers are gone
etc
how would you
how would you rebuild would i rebuild
would you rebuild yeah i guess that's
the first question that's the question
because i suppose if
if it's all lost right it means that
there's another chance to try again now
it's another chance to reinvent so if i
had to rebuild it i guess i guess you
would just relaunch your channel and
like say guys we're back and then try
again but i think maybe i would go down
a new route like maybe i would think
about instead of being on camera maybe
i'll write instead so i'll now go to
zimbabwe and work with cam fed um and
then maybe write articles about what i'm
seeing or maybe i go down there and i i
now
run help run the organization right i
think i'd still be making impact but
maybe in a different way i don't know if
i would
do it on the internet necessarily now
it's like i'm in the flow of things that
it's happening but i don't see myself on
the internet forever i don't see it
being here for me beyond five years now
so in three years if this phd goes ahead
like i definitely
love documenting when i'm studying and i
love speaking to the student community
but like once i
i'm done i don't know if i i don't think
i would enjoy it anymore that's the
honest truth so i see myself that
there's like a three year to five
maximum
um lifetime on this and then i might tap
out and um
yeah like i definitely don't see it in
my
post study world with me like i
definitely don't it's not something that
i want to do
and it's not something i'm going to do
but um
yes i've had to rebuild i think i'd be
really happy actually
because it's like well what can you do
it shut down what was going to happen
yeah
and it would just be like a new
existence like it's just a new world
like you would now live within your
means like if the youtube money stops
it's like you just adjust you downsize
on the apartment
you move to a city that's cheaper and
you figure out a way of living that
suits what you're doing and now you're
not on the internet like it's not even
like
you have any any
any requirements or like right now it's
like i need the office right like yes i
could technically just be at home but
like the you know you need to put all
your lights up and the family's sleeping
at certain times and you're hi guys
there's a lot you know i need my own
space i need the office i need to do
that whereas when you're no longer in
that world yeah your work is at it's
over there like you go home just to
sleep we don't need all of this what
we've got right now right so
i would just i would just start a new
route to be honest
i think i'll be happy
um what quote or mantra do you live by
oh
that is that is really good there's
three that already come to mind
the top one is
that you're deserving of everything you
want in the world right that one i
believe to my i tell myself this every
day because now there's nothing unless
i'm just not qualified for it like
you're not gonna put me
in the surgeon's chair because i'm gonna
someone's gonna die yeah i'm not gonna
be able to save the life right but
if i were to go to medical school and i
was a qualified doctor
but in my field in my lane there's like
like why there's nothing that is too
about if i'm human i'm here and some
other human can do it too so can i then
the other one is definitely my rejection
one like the whole idea of rejection is
redirection failure is another chance to
try again it means that life
it never stops you still have a chance
every day you wake up you get to to to
start fresh
it's never like oh it's too late you're
never too old
do that degree 45 okay
you can still hit here you can still go
in and take information and write notes
you can go to school
and finally journey or destination
ah
of course it's the journey it's gonna be
done of course it's the journey
destination is a bonus yeah journey is
the beauty of it the journey is the fun
part the journey is where it's at
because that is where you learn where
you grow
and where you get to create and exist
and then the destination is like ah we
got here and even when you get to
destination you're still on the journey
and that that's the tea
thank you so much there's been enough oh
my gosh i think this is the longest
interview we've ever done no way we've
been talking for over two and a half
hours so
um i just want to say yeah thank you
thank you so much it's been a real joy
like i think the the passion that you
exude is just so infectious
um it's like experiencing it in real
life is like
it's it's like on another level compared
to like on youtube or in instagram
stories so yeah i just think it's been
fantastic and i've taken a lot of a lot
of like
really like yeah life life lessons away
from it um and i guess you aren't really
trying to be a guru as such but like i
think you're just like accidentally just
like ridiculously inspiring so
um i'm sure everyone who who watches
listen listen we'll get a lot of value
from it guys check the book out link in
all the things
um and yeah it's gonna be everywhere in
the stores like go and look for it which
smith water stones i don't know how to
say the word foils follies whales never
heard of it yeah it's a bookshop that's
a bookshop okay cool
it's one of the pretty big ones out
there but yeah it'll be in there as well
nice wherever and i just i just hope
that people who read it just
find it motivational and practically
helpful
and that when you finish reading it puts
a smile on your face that's all i want
i'm sure it will
and i can't wait to do a proper video
about it
lots of really useful lessons that i
think can be turned into a nice little
nice little video um yeah thanks and uh
guys thanks for listening and hit the
subscribe button and check out v all
links in the video description and we'll
catch you later right that's it for this
week's episode of deep dive thank you so
much for watching check out v's book
it's generally very good it's a work of
art links to these socials and her book
and all the things in the video
description and the show notes and
wherever you're watching this please do
check the link in the video description
in the show notes that will be a link to
apple podcasts to leave a review for the
podcast if you like this episode i'd
love for you to leave a review because
it genuinely does help more people
discover the podcast anyway thank you so
much for listening have a great day and
i'll see you in the next episode bye